A difficult situation occurs every day,
their units are constantly replenished
with manpower, the artillery
works quite intensively and advances
little by little, but our units hold back
[music]
our guys are holding the defense and in some
directions the territory that
was temporarily occupied is difficult, but the
guys are heroes and stand despite
the frost, the swamp, the
battles are brutal, I
sent you a video where they are just
climbing on their corpses, where a guy is sitting
in a trench, corpses are around him, he doesn't
know what to do anymore, he is just preparing
for death and smoking, throwing the bull of his
comrades
who are lying around him,
climbing and climbing  they shot him, he
continued to climb in front of him, they killed his
comrade there, his head was blown off, he continued to
climb, well, you understand the situation is
such that they were threatened with death there, they
will either die here or die there.
they
are brought out in public and read like that  they are
deserters and the guys are so nice to them, they are
just shot by
two or three men in front of the formation, even if they
had to throw a machine gun, it is a monkey with a machine gun,
and if there are many of them, it is still a big problem,
there is a strong enemy against us,
but we are stronger, we will drive him out